okay looks like we're live but we have
to we have to run a test to see if
everything is working can you hear me
Stephano yes loud and clear okay loud
and clear there's 44 people people can
you please write on the chat and tell us
if you can hear us and speak us because
before I was talking to Stefan but
Stefan couldn't hear so he was like I
was talking and talking for like five
minutes he was like yeah yeah and you
know
okay I cannot still see if you're
leaving comments by the way uh I'm
broadcasting this through uh streamyard
so this is a little bit different from
what we did before what I've what I've
been doing in the last uh in the last
months we can see the comments but we're
not on YouTube directly on streamyard
but for you it doesn't change anything I
can see myself on YouTube through the
iPad okay it looks like everything is
fine sounds good everything is okay Matt
says mike Mika nice to see you mik mik's
a student of the academy but without
further Ado let's talk about my guest so
my guest he goes by the name of Stefano
lingu and that's his channel Stefano is
one of my best friends is an amazing guy
um he not just an amazing person but
also a very competent polyglot and we
got to know each other I don't remember
Stefan exactly maybe seven years ago
when when was it that we got to know
each other I don't remember probably
around six or seven yeah six or seven
years ago I will let Stephano introduce
himself but again Stephano is just an
amazing polyglot one of the the most
competent people and the thing I like
the most about stepan is that we can
spend like Stephan is the kind of person
with whom I could spend like three days
talking without even sleeping talk about
language running life and everything in
between we send each other messages and
what's up every day just an amazing guy
Stephano so who are you for just
introduce yourself for the people who do
not know you and the languages you speak
and a little bit of your kind of
linguistic background okay before we
start and then I'll introduce the topic
and everything else hi luuka hi
everybody uh it's great to be here first
of all and thank you for the amazing
introduction I'm not sure I deserve it
but still you do you do you do well as
Luka said my name is Stefano I'm from
Milan
Italy uh I grew up in a monolingual
environment but uh pretty soon I started
noticing how much I loved uh foreign
languages and I have
dedicated all my life to foreign
languages uh learning them teaching them
creating content and and courses
nowadays I'm creating courses so uh it's
it's been really my passion and my life
this is why my channel is called lingua
which in Italian means uh language and
passion or if you will language is
Passion you can do that little
you can write by the way you can write
your um uh the link of your YouTube
channel please on the chat so that
people can find it for those all right
you left in the world who don't know
Stephano Soh okay we're gonna talk more
about the languages that Stephanos
speaks he speaks a bunch of interesting
languages we have I think six languages
in common but he speaks also Georgian
Icelandic uh Finnish he's famous for his
Finnish because you speak at at home but
you know it's it's rare to find people
who speak finish that well so um you can
find this channel in the chat I don't
know if you've left a comment in the
chat this is the first time first for I
just found out I cannot you cannot okay
okay so I remind you guys we were using
a slightly different system we will
going to highlight your comments every
time that someone asks an interesting
question you're going to see it on the
screen so this is a little bit of a
different format I'm going to find uh
Stephano's channel here let me see if I
can I don't know why you can't post
that's strange uh but we're going to
solve the problem technical problems
here uh there we go so this is your
Stefanos channel that I'm going to post
here for those who want to uh take a
look I hope that yes you can see it okay
so um as far as I'm concerned I I'm
going to send you uh also going to send
your your way um some ad so to speak and
that is about the ebook that I've just
um I've just published and it's
completely free on my website so for
those who signed up i' I've been
receiving a lot of uh a lot of um Love
Letters not love letters but love
messages um telling me that they love
the book so you just subscribe to the
newsletter and you will get an email and
you can you can just download the ebook
and the audiobook that comes with it
completely for free and a bunch of other
tips to start learning a language
improve your languages become a polyglot
and everything in between
so now uh let's do a wrap up of what
this is about this conversation so it's
the first time that I invite a guest uh
and we talk live so uh it's it's a first
it's the first time that I invite
Stefano live we're GNA talk about how to
learn a foreign language how to start
learning a foreign language more
specifically if you like this we're
going to send a poll after this couple
of days after asking you did you like it
what is it that you liked what is it you
didn't like and then we're if you like
it we can do another one about maybe
overcoming the intermediate Plateau
become a poly learning multiple
languages at the same time wherever you
want lovely guys so someone
writes both well LCA lello estano it's
kind of Tian sounding
names uh but in this another important
thing we speak English we're going to be
speaking English in this very same live
but upon request we can change the
language we could even do it
multilingual live but we believe that
speaking in multiple languages is cool
uh we've done we already made a video
that was not live but the problem is
that we're going to lose some people
because if Stefano starts talking in
Georg not even
I walk out the room say okay well that's
that's it like the other time started
you know started speaking Georgian or
Finnish I go like okay well this is
fantastic but I don't understand a word
okay so without further ado by the way
oh of course of course we have some
languages in common we have some other
languages that we do not have in common
but that's uh that's the beauty of it
okay so let's get started um so here's
how it's going to work um we're going to
talk we're gonna um tackle a few topics
within the main topic of how to start
learning a language and then you guys
can ask questions and we will answer so
we will select some of the questions you
can ask questions later uh because if
you ask questions now then they're going
to get lost in the in the in the dungeon
there of the comment so pay attention
take a take a pencil or paper Just J
down stuff because there's a lot to
learn in this conversation especially
from Stefano so let's get started
Stefano and let's talk about how you
start learning a
language what do you do just like so
just like so okay yes so first of all um
I have to start with with an answer that
is a bit uh um not the most favorite
answer that you that you can hear and it
is that it depends on the language to be
quite honest so I I really think that I
cannot approach Mandarin Chinese the
same way I approach uh Finnish or
Georgian it really depends on on on the
type of of language that that I'm
approaching the uh my my point of the
point where I start from you know so uh
as an Italian speaker who already knows
uh maybe German very well maybe starting
to learn a language like
Dutch will be a completely different
thing uh compared to starting to learn
Japanese right but with this said uh we
can probably talk about a more General
approach that uh I would use to to
approach a new language right now if I
were to start today or as it really
happened with a new language that I that
I started learning this year uh what
what I'm doing okay so uh first the
first thing is that I'm going to stick
to only a few
resources okay I'm Jing down notes I'm
jotting down notes stick to so yes
that's that's excellent so stick I I
really want to I really want to to hear
uh what people think about this because
I really have the feeling that in
today's world with so many opportunities
that the internet is giving
us uh the risk of losing track because
of just how much we could do we could we
could like uh potentially uh do uh how
many resources we could potentially use
to learn a language we we end up trying
10 20 different things and never getting
anywhere you know we can we we can do so
much but we end up doing very very
little I I have come to understand that
if I stick to just a few resources just
maybe one textbook uh that I can use as
a main structure uh of my my course
that's my that's my course of action
okay I'm following the the textbook
maybe one or two YouTube channels to
just keep listening a lot to the
language and maybe a one podcast to to
listen when I have some uh idle time or
while I'm doing uh the washing up and
stuff uh and that's
enough oh someone is saying louder
please if I if I keep my mic I can I can
hear you very well but if you keep your
microphone closer to your mouth I can
hear you even better I don't know
about please guys tell us if okay louder
for Stephano can you hear me well when I
speak because I have I have something
similar but it's not quite the same but
I don't think it makes any difference if
I if I put it it's closer can you hear
me better or it doesn't change anything
I think people can hear for you I think
it was okay change the stuff yeah
actually I'll hold this up no problem
you're gonna be numb at the end Anil
they say it Anil is a nice word okay
that Baron says it's better okay we can
hear you better so just just let me
recap guys if you want I'm also
interacting with you in the chat so I'm
not interrupting Stefan but I'm just
writing for example how many resources
you to start I wrote stick to a few
resources that's a key element for me as
well going I talk to you what about what
I do but the bottom line is that first
of all Stephano made a very interesting
point that um when you learn a language
he's got a different approach we're
going to go you know go deeper into this
but he's got a different approach
depending on the language as far as I'm
concerned I have always this a very
similar Approach at the beginning as a
core like the core is the B Direction
translation method for those who know me
uh you know that I that I use this
method but I would contend that stepan
has a very interesting point and I'm
going to talk about um you know for
example Portuguese versus say Turkish uh
in a bit after Stefano has made all the
points interesting points he is making
so everybody's saying no we he you well
whenever there's a problem you cannot
hear us something happen happens in the
background Stefano I don't know goes
crazy you just just let us know so okay
so so um yeah I think this this is the
the first the first point uh so choosing
choosing one main uh resource and uh and
then going with that wait wait wait you
said a few resources you didn't say one
resources said yeah one main like the
one couple of video a couple of uh
channels and one podcast that's it
that's it you know so for for the for
the beginning
uh okay give us can you give us a very
specific example of something you did
for one maybe let's say a close language
again there's close languages and more
distant languages I don't like thinking
you know about languages in terms of
difficult and easy they're more like
complex depending on our own native
language and the languages we already
have our under our belt so can you give
us an example of you know a relatively
close language that you've learned close
to your Nave language or languages you
already speak fluently and a language
that completely alien to anything you've
seen before sure so for Romanian
Romanian is a Roman language I'm Italian
so we have like 70% of the of the vocab
that is uh like mutually intelligible so
that's I think a good example um I
started uh I I went to a course actually
like in person for for Romanian it was a
great course and I used the the one book
that we had uh on that course you know
so that was my my main uh Resource as a
textbook and then I discovered a a very
very uh nice uh resource on YouTube uh a
guy that talks about uh space
exploration
in I know you like it as well
F no not that one not he speaks Italian
right that's true f is like an amazing
Romanian guy but he speaks Italian he's
got a YouTube channel and one of my
faite it's called do desio do Des okay
yeah like a space do and so I and I used
to I used to just listen to it at the
beginning I wasn't understanding all
that much but uh it was a great uh great
way to practice listening
comprehension for a language like
Georgian for example I started with the
book that uh maybe I have here no it's
it's not here uh very very simple based
on dialogues I have videos where I show
on my channel where I show where I show
uh this this book and talk and talk
about why it's it's so good I think um
and then I discovered a couple of um
Georgian uh people who are really really
lovely and sharing their their language
on
YouTube um and that's it and the name of
the book if you're interested is
beginner beginners Georgian it's really
good if you interested in learning
Georgia one day go for it the great
thing is it doesn't get you bed down on
too much grammar and we are going to
talk about grammar a lot uh during this
live I I have the feeling uh but this
this is also a a very important Point uh
not trying
to uh not wanting to learn it all from
the start like uh and understanding 100%
of Georgian grammar like the first week
that's just impossible extremely
counterproductive um getting bed down
with too much information is so so bad
yes yes I agree and this is something
that I've learned to uh to go about in a
different way through the years because
I've spent like 25 years learning
languages and um I'm no longer the
youngest one Let's uh me neither me
neither so and I have the feeling I've
matured even as a learner not only as a
man
hopefully uh so like at the beginning I
would uh spend too much time and energy
on trying to understand it all from the
start like I did for Finnish uh back in
the day but what I did with Georgian and
what I'm doing right now with my new
language is um completely different you
know okay excellent Stan One Step at
time at a time one step at a time I
would like to add my two cents and then
I'm going to read uh some of the
questions but as you will see magic
let's see if this works it's the first
time I'm just going to highlight some of
the comments and we can tackle them
together I hope Stephanie will see it
too but I'm going to do this in a second
so use if I'm just going to recap this
for myself and for the people are
listening to us so basically you say
when you start learning a language you
have different a different approach
depending on the language if it's a
language that is very similar to your
native language or a language you
already know like Romanian for example
you got yourself a nice core uh book
like material and you also got a podcast
right on well podcast or videos that you
watch in this case this guy from from
space that talk who talks about space
rather than from space and then when
when it comes to another uh like a more
complex language you have a slightly
different approach an example of that is
Georg
Georgian uh Stephano promised me he's
going to show me his Georgian stuff so
and by the way he did did a wonderful
workshop last year with the polyga
gather we had a lot of fun and that I I
told myself this language is tough but
it's fun you know so I one day I will
tackle georan because it looks beautiful
and it sounds beautiful so different
approaches depending on on which
language you learn as far as I'm
concerned I always use where is it I put
it here I said okay I'm G to show this
to everybody and now I can't find it
it's uh it's my assimil Turkish uh I
honestly don't know what happened it's
not here for whatever reason but I've
shown it multiple times so basically I
always use one resource and apply that
method for to that one
resource however um Stephano is right is
like hit the nail in the head as they
say that sometimes I tell myself okay I
started learning Romanian I started
learning um Japanese I started learning
portugu Portuguese in particular
Portuguese and Romania these are two
glaring examples of why sometimes it's
good to change your mind or to change
your approach is that since I am Italian
I already speak Spanish doing the B
Direction translation back and forth
back and forth and then waiting a long
time before speaking can actually be
counterproductive because I actually
realized every three months even if I
was doing ju Portuguese just for 10
minutes a day just for 15 20 minutes a
day then after three months I could
already speak I could have I could have
started speaking from the get-go if you
learn Catalin uh Spanish Portuguese so
it's it's good to have a core method but
it's also nice to tweak it sometimes
same thing for Japanese like B Direction
translation works fine but you have to
adapt it to Japanese and the fact that I
was using aimal so I was you know a
little bit stuck uh I was as stubborn as
a mu was they say that okay I have this
one resource a trust that I've used it
before it's G to work I have my method
I'm gonna apply that ain't gonna cut it
and it didn't cut it and it ain't going
to cut it when it comes to Japanese
using it this way so um this is a very
important point um as I said as far as
I'm concerned I use a you know a
different method because I believe that
when it comes to learning a language
it's not so much as methods that count
it's the principles Stefano follows
Universal principles of good learning
and reaches the outcome it's just like
moving from A to B and different people
follow different paths but they reach
the same destination now I'm going to
start opening the the the show so to
speak I'm just going to highlight some
of the comments I'm just going to go up
because there's a lot of interesting
comments here and again you guys are
amazing thank you so much for asking so
many comments if I skip some of the
comments that's just because we're human
beings there's a lot of comments here
and we have we don't have a lot of time
so um someone asks there you go
um well this this comment is not so much
about attending coures no but actually
it is let's start with that so Anonymous
user says I think you can see it on
screen could you guys maybe say
something about the pros and cons of
attending courses I know Luka learns by
himself but there are surely some
advantages as well I'll say something
just just for a second before uh Stefano
chimes in I talked yesterday to famed
Richard simut whom I'm gonna invite to
the show we're gonna have a live show as
well if you guys want I'm pretty sure
you everybody knows Rich Sim cut and
yesterday I had a nice chat with him and
he was telling me that you know Richard
learn has learned a lot of languages
Richard simut this very famous guy who
speaks a bunch of languages you can
watch him on YouTube and he's got a very
once again he's got a very different
approach than mine he goes attend
attends basically University classes or
you know courses learns language learns
a language learns the basics goes out
there talks to people very different
from me and completely legit as they say
Stephan what do you think about this
yeah absolutely absolutely uh the three
of us uh have uh basically different
approaches uh but as you as you said
uh we tend to all get somewhere at a
certain point so maybe we can make a
case that it's not so
important uh how and what you do but how
much you want it you know so I have the
feeling that sometimes like motivation
and and the ability of uh the ability to
to organize your study uh and to go out
to go out there and and practice is even
even more important that the the method
that you use or the book that you chose
stuff like that so Absolut to the to the
question though uh PR and cons of
attending courses I've done both things
I've attended courses and I've studied
languages completely uh on my own and um
I have to say that some of the best pros
of attending
courses is um finding other people uh
maybe from your from your town
that you can you can hang out with they
have the same passion they like the same
language they want to they want to learn
uh maybe you want to travel with them to
to the to the country I've met I I
attended some Japanese courses here in
Brussels uh after I moved uh to Belgium
and uh some of my best Belgian friends
are still people from that course I'm
absolutely
grateful uh for that you know so um
meeting other human beings is really
what what what what it is about same
thing for my uh Romanian
course uh I met a a young woman who
who's a very good friend of
mine ER so that's that's the beauty of
it I think meeting with other people who
who have the same passion and you know
if you if you want to to be with people
go ahead and attend a course there are
there are cons of course the main one if
I if I can um just mention one is that
um you are going at a pace that uh you
are not deciding you are not deciding
the pace
uh yes there are going to be yeah there
are going to be people who uh know the
language already better than you and you
have the feeling they're going too fast
or on on the other hand uh maybe
you understand it much better and you're
learning fast but you have the feeling
that someone is slowing you down it's
part of
the part of life part of yeah excellent
answer I would just add very shortly
that for me as as you correctly pointed
out going to a class has its pros and
cons but whatever happens the most
important thing is what you do at your
place if you do something on top of of
the class because the class is okay but
then you know for example when I was
learning Latin I really like doing
things by myself and I Advanced I made a
lot of progress and everybody was you
know I was making more progress than the
others just because I was doing stuff at
home so known in
schim which means it's a Latin saying
that we don't learn at school but we
learn from life as you know this
literally translated anyway excellent
answer as always Stefano I um Carlo asks
dear St what kind of material did you
use to tackle the writing of the Chinese
characters um I have Asim Asim chines
Asim Chinese but I do not know how to
start with the writing
part H all right so uh while you answer
while you answer I'm going to go grab
something if I find it so please answer
I'm GNA stay here I'm just going to find
this one resource that we're gonna miss
you Luka we're gonna miss you to come
back so when I when I started learning
Chinese actually I already
had a fair uh knowledge of uh Japanese
characters and that helped me a lot more
than I thought uh so I kept I kept
writing them on on paper because like a
good a good chunk of them are very
similar or like the basics is is similar
so I just kept writing them on paper but
there are some um apps I think one of
them is called scritor but I'm I don't
want to uh like say the the wrong wrong
name I think scripter
um it uh it helps um it gives you tasks
you you have to um to copy to copy the
characters uh first with a hint and then
without so it's really really really
well uh well prepared well uh organized
and uh I also used uh
Anki uh because there is the option on
Anki if I remember well um um if I
remember correctly Anki has the option
to to let you write by hand with your
finger I also used uh for Japanese
though not for Chinese but it's it's the
same principle I also used uh the
Nintendo what what what was it called it
it's it's a few years ago guys I'm sorry
before no Nintendo no no the the
Nintendo uh the one that you can open
you can open like this you have like a a
small pen and and you can write on
screen that was great great that was
amazing I could take it with me uh in
the underground and then just uh and
just uh keep um practicing the uh uh the
characters the DS thank you thank you
very much Nintendo DS yeah exactly uh
you can find a lot of programs on
Nintendo DS for uh for that maybe it's
it's outdated now nowadays but uh I
think I think it's called scit I'm GNA
do some research I let uh Luka speak and
then I I'll get back with the correct
name I I don't have much to say about
apart from the fact that I did not find
what exactly what I was looking for but
I found something similar so it's
exactly the same concept for Asimo you
have a specific book for this is for
writing this
Japes so it's like easy Japanese or
something like that Japanese with ease
and you have um you know it's a it's a
book that is really specific I hope you
can see this but you should be able to
see that it's a book that is very
specific to uh building the skill of
writing you know kanji in this case but
the Asim has an identical book also for
for Chinese so it's exactly the same
thing if you look uh chines s for so
Chinese with ease stepan is gonna leave
us for a little bit Chinese with ease um
H so it's a Chinese characters you will
easily find it I think it's still there
still around yeah so
uh if you I can't see it so you have
to this
is it's the same thing it's the same
thing that you have but this is from
Germany okay fantastic anyway the app is
called scripter that's
that's i' heard about that anyway I see
there's a lot of questions so let's go a
little bit faster and you
know we're gonna try to uh reply to as
many uh many uh you know questions as
possible let's let's see this one is a
is in Icelandic uh I don't know how to
pronounce it but it's like
something again it means like how's it
going probably how's it go how is
iteland and by the
way all all I'm I'm trying to do uh is
uh to maintain it so not to forget what
I've learned so far I have a wonderful
friend called
MIM uh who I do tandem with um like
every week uh and we switch from Italian
to to Icelandic so that's that's enough
not to forget uh but I'm not actively
learning okay great as far as I'm I'm
concerned islandic beautiful language
beautiful country I've been reading a
book fascinating book by an Italian guy
who lives in Iceland I will definitely
learn this language now we have again
this is going to last more or less one
hour and a half for those who want to
stay and I see more and more people
coming so this is great uh we have
though more stuff to talk about in in
particular mindset the mindset of a
beginner vocabulary grammar
pronunciation and organization these are
the five big topics so what we're going
to do is going to try to answer like not
not super fast but we're GNA try to
answer a few other uh questions from you
and then we're gonna move on today
exactly this is an Italian
gesture which means this is actually
Roman dialect it's not even Italian like
go to the point
so um let's do this fast can you write
the name of the Italian Space Channel
I've already done it's called four
fourk Universe I think it's 4K Universe
by it
by Adrian Fades this is Romanian guy who
speaks Flawless Italian I'm always I'm
always super apart from the fact he
super smart but it's one of my favorite
YouTubers uh fast please Stefano which
language is the new one for Stefano Ana
sh shall we shall we reveal
already yeah you can reveal it it's a
fun thing because it's the first time
that this has happened H Luca and I are
learning the same language right now and
that's Turkish so it's the first time
ever that Luka and I learn the same
language yes the Turkish resource that I
can't find can't find anything today I
don't know what's going on but just I I
I was pretty I had it here and for
whatever reason I can't find it doesn't
matter okay so uh I'm going to skip some
of of the of the questions guys because
some are really open-ended questions it
would take a long time but again you can
Reas the question and we we will try to
go through as many as possible please
Stefano be fast I'll try to answer as
fast as I can okay this is a big one uh
so Osvaldo says uh hello dear Luka what
a pleasure and privilege to be here live
greetings from underground well
underground like okay valdo thank you
very much for the comment this is not a
question but it's more like a
declaration of love y joov I have no
clue how to pronounce this what is your
opinion about com compreh I guess you
wanted to say comprehensible but com
compressible input is not bad is it's
like what is compressible input
comprehensible in input as a method can
you reply in one minute Stefan I know
this in one minute I'll try I'll try my
best try it yeah I'll try my best so I
think it's a it's a f F inting uh method
to to acquire languages I think it works
better um for specific languages like
for specific specific situations that is
when you're learning a language that is
that is similar or closer uh to your own
native language or to a language that
you know already very very well I think
it's going to be uh even more powerful
uh it's going to be much less powerful
for me for example to just start with
Turkish like from zero and only only
listening to Turkish people speaking uh
because I don't have enough um footholds
you know uh and personally I love
grammar I'm a grammar freak I I I I like
I like understanding the structure what
what is like hidden behind uh
the grammar freak yeah yeah you know you
know what it means so I prefer I prefer
understanding the building blocks of of
a language rather than just being yes
okay this is another gesture which means
I think I'm done I think I'm done so
very very I'm sorry I didn't want to be
rude but I'm just saying we try to
answer like it's also a skill to answer
as many we're gonna learn even I just
tend to ramble anyway to answer your
question y I think comprehensible input
is really important it's at the base of
everything for language acquisition and
learning but as Stefan pointed out it's
also important sometimes to uh you know
use your own approach especially when it
comes to learning uh completely
different languages if I apply the
comprehensible input just like reading
stuff in Turkish I from the Geto I would
be completely lost um we read already
oswaldo's comments I'm G to read two
more comments three more and then we're
gonna uh talk about mindset so cool um
47 I
start
which means basically I've been using
the B Direction translation method the
one method I um I I use and uh we have
this this course in the academy with
Korean and I've made a lot of progress
thank you co coo I think that's
Christina says uh hi looka greetings
from Houston greeting Houston Texas we
got a problem from Houston right that's
that's the famous thing Houston Tex
Houston we got a problem uh we don't
have a problem here
Christina uh Now Tracy this is a really
interesting question but let's talk
about specifically questions related to
learning a language because Tracy asks
how can you not confuse languages but uh
this is an amazing question but uh
please ask questions that are specific
to how to start learning a language so
we can keep it modular granular and
specific to this topic and then if you
guys like it we can do other lives and
talk about anything you want so um
I want Asim for Turkish but do not have
it for English speakers can you
recommend material with the same format
or a progressively more difficult text
this is a very good uh good question uh
and a nerve I do not know because I've
just bought aimil and I haven't explored
any resources but maybe just maybe our
beloved Stefano has resource for it so N
I can tell you uh for Turkish I'm I'm I
am going to to try uh teach yourself the
teach yourself series for Turkish it's
english-based so that could be a
resource that is useful for you too I
haven't used it yet so I cannot tell you
whether or not it's good but I have used
teach yourself in the past for Finnish
Norwegian and Romanian I have it
somewhere uh and I loved the content and
I love the approach uh the building up
the grammar like step by step
uh instead of trying to cram it all in
in one lesson so uh let's try it out
together let's try okay I will I will
definitely buy it excellent one more
question Jo from joavan RTI is it
possible to start a new language without
a solid why that burning point which
pushes us to begin please and with this
one we're also going to talk about
mindset what it what does it mean to
start a language without knowing why or
without or knowing exactly why you want
to learn a language
so you can answer that um stepan I was
about to say Joan Joan is the one
question Stephano is the one answering
so um what what do you think can you
start language without without knowing
why just like for the sake of it is hey
let's this is such a fantastic question
this is such a fantastic question I'm
all years I'm all yours it's much more
powerful than than you would think
remember two minutes max no one minute
you have one minut one minute yeah one
minute so uh I think I think it is
possible to start learning a new
language without a solid why but you
won't get very far that's my uh my first
uh answer if I have to think about it um
I've done it in the past I've studied a
couple of languages in the past that I I
didn't really even want to learn I knew
that I didn't really want to I just
wanted to to see how it is and I can
confirm I did not continue uh the ones
that I had a solid why for are still in
my life today after are still in my life
like beautiful ladies that you courted
they're still in your life you know
they're orbiting around Stefanos like a
constellation of elements okay excellent
answer and let's talk about mindset okay
so what are the things that you believe
the false ideas or uh the false beliefs
that people hold when it comes to
learning languages when it comes to
starting to learn a language so let's
let's imagine that Among The 100 70
people are actually watching right now
and all those who are going to watch
this later there's a bunch of people
who've tried to learn the language
before maybe they were at college and
they were at school and after five years
of to much toil and sweat they still do
not speak and they think I'm not good at
languages what would you say what's your
answer because you've also worked as a
teacher as a coach what's your answer to
someone who comes to you and says try to
language I tried to learn a language
before and I'm not good enough my memory
is not good enough I'm too old or I'm
just not good I don't have the language
Gene I haven't been blessed with the
language gene or whatever in most cases
the truth is that they have learned
something they just have far too high
expectations uh of becoming fluent by uh
maybe not really putting in a a a or
creating a real routine creating uh this
need to to learn this passion uh to to
learn every day or or um consistently
and another very very important thing is
that I've noticed
uh people um tend to not consider their
own Pro progress as enough as if someone
else uh were there to tell them you are
not enough you did not learn fast enough
you did not learn uh effectively enough
you know but who are other people to
tell you maybe you you yourself you are
telling yourself that you're not enough
so very very often I've been more of a
psychologist than an actual teacher when
I've helped when I've helped people um
improve their language
skills uh understanding that every
single word that we learn every single
thing new thing that we learn is a step
forward is very important uh I I very
often uh urge people to look back at I
don't know some time in the past and
reflect to um to reflect
about what's what has changed what I can
do today that I wasn't able to do three
months ago and very often they realize
oh wait a minute yeah today I could
actually answer this question and I was
not able to answer it three months ago
and that's already a big step forward
forward so
celebrating the little
conquests uh the little goals is so
important and
not um stressing too much about results
I really think that if we trust in the
in the process if we trust in what we do
every day to learn one day the results
will be there the more we focus on oh I
want the results I want the results the
less we are going the the the more time
it's going to take us you know so for
example my mindset
is step by step one little step at a
time I know that one day I'm going to
get somewhere okay I'm not stressing
about when am I going to speak fluent
Turkish I actually don't care I don't
care because I love it I love just like
I don't care like someone asked me when
are I gonna I don't care I don't care
I'm enjoying the process itself
absolutely enjo of learning this is
absolutely inspiring St thank you and I
I don't want to interrupt you it's just
that you know we have so much stuff to
say uh I I would just add this one thing
uh you hit the nail on the head once
again about the fact that we focus a lot
on on the outcome I don't know guys what
you think maybe you can write it in the
chat but think about this when you go to
school when you when you went to school
what do you think what do you think
about marks right you think about the
results you think oh I have to do well
or someone ask you something and you
have to answer I have to do well right
and let's let's let's suppose that let's
assume that maybe you're in a class
right and someone uh or the teacher asks
you point blank something and then you
answer in whatever language French
that's suppose French or Spanish you're
not thinking about like the pleasure of
communicating you're focusing on the
outcome so it's really important that
this unfortunately comes from years and
years of of uh traditional education
quote unquote where we focus on the
outcome we do not focus on
um on the actual process that's the
reason why when people ask me Luka why
would why are you learning so many
languages is because like sit down every
day it's it's a complete pleasure it's
just like like hey today I'm just gonna
hit Turkish you know hit the books
Turkish first thing in the morning 5:30
people might think I'm crazy but that's
another matter okay so wonderful uh so
we're talked a little bit about mindset
uh stepan address this let's go back to
the questions uh I'm going to go now to
the end so we're going to I'm going to
just do
both the end and a little bit up this is
what I always
do uh let me see totally agree with
Stephano enjoy the journey and Trust the
process Mikela Marcelino says Mikela
um Baron says master of any sufficiently
complex skill takes time this is another
very important thing it might sound
trivial and obvious but it's not
anything good comes with time takes time
to speak a language that's the reason
why I know that just we just embarked
upon Turkish by the way we're going to
show you what we do so wait still stay
until the end we're going to show you
some of stuff on our
screen uh but uh but yeah uh I think
this is an important point when it comes
to mindset people want to know right I
was like they see people online hey this
guy's been learning uh Turkish Chinese
Georgian for one week one month and then
he speaks fluent he shows you that he
speaks that's not true trust me it takes
two three four years and of immersion
and through toil and sweat Balan breath
and I know who hides behind Balan breath
that's our friend um Alex from Serbia
whom you met uh at the PO Gathering oh
Alex hi Alex my wife told me that I have
one year to learn Arabic or else she
will divorce me and take the kids with
her to Dubai what can I do he always
asks the squirky
questions so what would you do your wife
was G tell you hey you have one year to
learn Arabic or she will divorce you
what's what okay so I know it's
difficult to address this but you let's
say behind this quirky question I would
say lies an interesting answer that
would be what would you do if you really
had to speak a language let's say at
least reach conversation influency
within uh within a year because your
life depends on it like would you know
how to structure I know I know the
answer it would take two hours to
explain it in detail there's a video
that I I talk about this how to learn a
language fast in six months even people
are obsessed by fast but what would you
do just give me what in one minute in
one minute what would you do I would
watch Lucas's
video
he didn't expect that okay well we're g
we gonna move on to the next question
but just very quickly I would say I
would do a very I would do a very
intensive program in like eight hours a
day I know that I would burn out uh you
know burn the handle so to speak but um
it's possible to learn faster but you
need intensity and you need frequency so
just do that for the entire day every
single day I would cut it to four but uh
but it's the same it's the same the same
concept right principle yeah yeah yeah
absolutely okay let's do a couple of
other questions and then let's talk
about vocabulary how do you learn
vocabulary this is uh something that
people are really interested in and uh I
think it's a it's it's a really
interesting topic you guys can listen
take notes and then ask your questions
so specific to how do you learn
vocabulary when you're a beginner not
just in general but when you're a
beginner because there's different
stages so let's see if there's any other
quirky
question let's see if anybody is asking
something else just find a new wife so
um D says just finding your wife that's
the problem it's not bad this is not bad
it's just a find I'm just gonna find
around the corner it's like what
language do you speak do you speak
Icelandic yes my wife um um this is an
interesting question Stephano do you
have any interest in learning another
unpopular language I wouldn't call it
maybe not pop maybe more than unpopular
exotic I would say exotic like laan or
example Bulgarian I don't know if
they're unpopular languages um depending
on the definition of unpopular I would
say maybe exotic like not a lot of
people learn latian apart from Richard
but Richard learns everything like if
you name any language in the world
whatever the had time ask him hey are
you learning Mai that was supposed to be
a joke and he said yes of course
lukino I started a
course you're now he's learning cornic
anyway so um hi Richard if you're
watching this this show live I'm not
sure but he's in in Malta right now
Ricardo morning learning maltes of
course goes without saying go without
saying well I think well finish Georgian
Icelandic um are already pretty EXO IC
so uh I right now I don't I don't feel
the need to learn any other language um
other than the the 13th that I the the
13 that I that I've learned in my life
and Turkish being the 13th so um I don't
know I don't know lvan has always um
interested me fascinated me um as a
Baltic language but I don't have
specific plans right now I just want to
this is maybe also something uh
interesting as a topic but not uh
nothing to do with today's topic and
that is that for me maintaining the
languages that that I have learned in my
life is nowadays even more important
than learning new ones big topic Big Top
we could we could make another live just
about four hour live of that four hour
live let's not dive into this right now
but just to let you
know okay so excellent um one more
question about um learning starting to
learn this is a very interesting
question and then we're going to talk
about vocabulary so okay Amo which
reminds me of penelo chingal for for
those at tians here from a certain
generation is penelo chingal is a famous
Grande pen what was it Grand well let's
forget about the Grande pelo how do you
tackle a language that is not exactly
new which you may already have acquired
in some way but never really studied to
reset your learning process and not
taking things for granted so interesting
maybe it's a language that you learned
before and you have a smattering of that
language and you go back in my case that
would be Romanian I try Romanian try my
hand at Romanian for a few months so
it's not a completely new language but
something keeps me from doing that
something keeps me from going back and
learning Romanian because it's not
completely new so in in my case it's
like if I learn a language from scratch
it would be amazing but I already know
what what to expect and that to me kind
of you know it it stops me from learning
a language somehow what would you do
You' done before it's almost as if uh it
it wasn't a new language for you uh so
you that's what stops you the same would
be for me with Dutch if I were to start
Dutch I also live in Brussels where
Dutch is spoken so well flamish actually
but uh it's one language actually uh so
I would
definitely uh do more listening and then
uh try to to imitate uh what I hear you
know more more and and surely go out go
out and talk talk with people much more
because that's what I did with Romanian
after two weeks of learning Romanian I
was already talking with people and they
they were like oh you speak Romanian and
I'm like uh not really but I'm faking it
and it's working because it's so similar
f it till you make it f it till you make
you can f it till till you make it so
more listening more listen more
listening okay excellent let's talk
about because we like 50 minutes have
gone by we still have 40 minutes we want
to talk tackle all these I promise we're
going to tackle all these and we want to
also on top of that show you something
like my Turkish stuff his Georgian stuff
so um let's talk briefly briefly Ana as
we
say um how do you learn um vocabulary
when you a complete beginner what are
you doing right now with Turkish for
example let's talk about that I'm
learning Turkish you're learning church
next question no I'm uh I'll tell you
why I said next question please because
uh vocabulary is my
weakness ah so yeah the magician has a
weakness you found
it in English you say a in the
armor you have a in the armor
you're in the armor yeah um I tend
to lag behind a bit uh with my vocab
compared with my understanding of
grammar of syntax of the structures how
the language works so why is that that's
probably because I don't find uh
learning vocabulary as uh fun pretty
simply as fun as I find learning the way
the the language works it's structured
Etc uh so but I need I need some vocab
right you
cannot um you cannot use the grammar
without the words let's face it yes for
me for me grammar is a skeleton is the
um the skeleton yeah
and vocab are muscles without muscles
nothing moves of course you need you
need the bones to be able to move so
even muscles alone just fall to the
ground I like the metaphor you you need
both right so to build up some muscle
what do I do uh I use repetition and
Association very very quickly because
otherwise luuka is going to SC me
yes
so repetition means simply repeat repeat
repeat as much as possible during the
day out loud you know maybe do you
repeat sentences do you repeat word
sentences phrases collocations both
both your wife sees you your wife sees
you speaking Icelandic going back and
then speaking Turkish going back yeah
like randomly on the street too yeah
that happens that happens I'm G to be
honest with you that
happens you know just just one thing
it's a funny thing I when I started
learning uh started learning Chinese not
only Chinese has different words
obviously for obvious reasons but it
also has tones right these ma ma ma ma
so I remember that we were sitting down
I was obsessed with Chinese I was
learning every day for like I don't know
one hour two hours there was a an
amazing software program that I was
using gave me marks for my pronunciation
and then I did it just before lunch and
then I was sitting in front of my my
father was on the other side of the
table and I was like and I was just
using my hands like this my father was
going like what the hell is going
on it's funny I was repeating constantly
words and stuff and my father thought
this guy is is G is going to go crazy my
mother used to say too many languages
your and your that I don't know after
20th language your brain is going to
explode anyway sorry so you repeat we
constantly repeating and Association
right I'll give you an example just to
make you understand uh there's a very
important word in Georgian and that's
the word for important that we can
uh agree that important is a very
important word okay but in in Georgian
it's very complicated
it's okay so just just to learn this one
to be able to say it like I just did it
took me two weeks of repeating every day
mishani in the shower like doing the
washing up Etc so my wife really
uh a bit a bit up
hearing every every concern concerned
about your mental
state it's it's like that and and also
Association so I try to uh find as many
footholds as many associations that I
can that I can make such as for example
for delicious the word for delicious in
Turkish is
Le and it starts with Le so in Italian
we
say when something is very very
delicious Leff so to leak your own
mustache okay yes and it starts with the
same two letters it seems really really
just unimportant but those two letters
help me make the association and already
now after a week I excellent okay I
always remember you it's already in you
okay so you associate it also with
sounds or parts of words that are
similar to words you already know okay
so repetition Association I have a lot
to say about this but I will uh I will
let uh the people ask questions I
already talked about this in numerous
videos if you type bual lamparello
vocabulary you will find three four
videos where I specifically tackle
vocabulary so if you want please go and
watch those um now o o I think he's
participated in various live shows thank
you for all the questions have you tried
the gold leaf method I think it's the
gold list method o but the gold leaf
maybe it's an an alternative method I
like it the gold leaf method sounds like
Poetic you see all these golden leaves
falling uh have you ever heard of this
gold list method Stefano oh yeah I have
heard about it but I haven't used it
okay uh the question is he's never tried
it I've never tried it uh for those who
are interested we don't have time now to
talk about it but the gold list method
it's a method use SRS system that space
repetition system where you constantly
review review and recall words so that
in order to memorize them those are were
interested you can uh take a look uh you
just write gold list method and you'll
find a lot of stuff there so
[Music]
um let's see let's see uh huh this is an
interesting question Tilman Ritter uh
love you guys a question how to get a
hang on cases in Slavic languages in my
case check I don't know if you've have
you learned any Slavic language no no
not yet all right so but but other other
languages with cases a lot so okay uh
can you give me a one minute reply how
do you how do you um let's say tackle
cases even if this is already in the
grammar in the grammar Zone but how do
you tackle cases okay so uh I try
to find or to give endings a
meaning even when they don't have
any uh which may sound a bit that's even
more concerning your wife your
wife like and sit down and tell your
wife i f try to find meaning where
there's no meaning in life I've talked
about this with her and she was like oh
all right so finish
enthusiasm I talk about this in a
actually in a Finnish uh podcast that I
participated in and uh and the the host
was uh was interested in this so
actually uh endings per se do not have
any uh meaning they don't bring any
meaning okay to the table
but I try to make
them sound in my head as if they had a
meaning so for example uh let's talk
about a the accusative is usually used
for objects right if I do something uh
like if I see someone or I take
something that something changes because
it's the object that I'm taking okay so
because I'm taking something I'm doing
I'm uh exing exing is that a word I I
don't know a for on it so it changes the
word and and I give the ending this
meaning I know it's it sounds a bit
complicated especially if you if you uh
if you're not um familiar with with
grammatical cases but this is my way of
of learning these so got it Luka go
ahead it's it's about Slavic languages
so you have a lot more to say I I wrote
an article about that you can find it on
the blog but the bottom line is uh
basically to get a lot of a lot of
exposure to highlight for example
different highlighters if you want to
the different cases and then deconstruct
and understand how these cases work I
know that this is not a thorough answer
but we're Runing out of out of time if
you want can take a look at the uh my
blog the article on the blog um now this
is a funny this is a funny one L and
Stefan I challenge you to do the Clos
Master 10 language 10 question each
challenge
oal I don't know I can't pronounce the
name because there's no vowels there
thank you exalt I think I can pronounce
the first one but not the second name
that appears there um you know funny
thing is we have been La last week when
we were preparing this live we thought
about doing a challenge that is pretty
similar to the one you are uh you you
want us to to get involved in and we are
going to do a different challenge but
it's going to be a fun one it's going to
be like us exposed basically it's G it's
gonna be we're g to try to do you know
try to do something difficult it's just
for the fun of it it's entertaining it
it could even um you know be a lovely
experience I doubt it but for us at
least we'll see we'll see um um Pablo
Pino asks do you write a list of new
phrases and words do you write them down
for example y yep I can show you so this
is these are my
little uh Turkish papers very very small
where I I write down the main like I
have a rule it's a two two we two We
Rule so I only write down stuff that I
really want to learn uh I'm going
through a course right now for example
for Turkish I encounter many many many
many many words am I writing them all
down no way I'm like
filtering what I get from the course
what I get from the resources I'm
using uh through my like um I'm only
taking the vocab that I I know that I'm
using like in two weeks am I am I going
to use the this word in my next
conversation or in two weeks when I
think about doing stuff in Turkish yes
then I write it down and I try to learn
it so otherwise you you just get like
overwhelmed with vocab that you won't
ever use and the problem with textbooks
is is precisely this uh they present you
with a lot a lot of words that you don't
need right away in in the first phases
of learning an new language language
right Luka what do you think about this
do you do this as well do you filter
filter out all the noise I agree
completely I just focus on the words I
need and I I just ignore like for
example the other day I stumbled upon a
word I don't even remember because I it
was not important for me I say I'll
never learn this word because it's
really not important I will never use it
I will never find myself in a situation
where I have to learn this word and a
lot of people get obsessed with learning
every single word that's not the way it
works you have to focus on what you need
because if even if you know like let's
say one thousand words you can create so
many sentences by combining them you
know so uh I I think that's a very
important Point let's move on to luchana
morbe I don't know Luana morbe I think
it's a Spanish sounding name hi is there
a site or an app to find expressions for
slang words in different language it's
an interesting question I I don't know
Rana I don't know maybe Stefan knows but
I don't know I don't know either I don't
know either okay so um another very
interesting question by anela segobia do
you think is is is it do you think it is
possible to master a language in six
months like from
scratch what does it mean to learn a
language well you have one minutes then
we have other stuff other fish to fry
sure it is possible it is possible uh I
can say I mastered
Portuguese in about five months and a
half but first of all I'm Italian second
of all I had already had a smattering a
smattering of Spanish
and I went to a course a university
course uh four hours a day and with a
lot of homework and other tasks to do in
the afternoon so it was hyper
intensive so yeah it is possible but
it's it's not going to be possible for
every language and for every phase of
your life I was a student I had time yes
I got nothing else to CH is just a
wonderful answer um okay so let's talk
about grammar but before we do please
stepan show us your Georgia your
beautiful georan and then I'm going to
show some stuff of my Turkish and then
we're going to resume the questions
talking about grammar so first you and
then now we got to figure out how to do
that so you have I think you have to
show your screen and I have to show I'm
gonna show you my screen uh this is what
I do show us your screen roll eyes okay
so let me see all see can you can you
guys see what I am seeing this beautiful
Georgian script I don't know if you can
um yeah it looks like because I'm
checking on my iPad here and it looks
like people can actually see that that's
great that's great so what is that all
about what's written there just help us
what is this
about um this is how I go about uh vocab
especially even some grammar things but
especially vocab this it has still to do
with vocab and after after um taking
notes on such little pieces of paper uh
I go through these during the day I can
I like to to go through these while I
walk so that's why I have I have them on
paper but when they when they're um I'm
I'm familiar with these Expressions I
tend to write them uh uh to type them
into a Google doc okay a Google document
that I can access from anywhere right
even when I'm in Italy visiting my
family I can access Google Docs and and
take a look and view some stuff so uh
what I do is I tend to
um to group uh vocabulary uh um
depending on the topic this is uh moaa
and that's traveling okay so uh I start
with a with a sentence such as I went to
London for the first time uh last week
MH and then I break down the pieces and
write down something in English with
variations like passenger is different
from uh travel like this is passenger
this is traveler there are these
differences only the stuff that I really
really really think is key uh okay only
key vocab not just not every single word
that I encounter but what is really
really important to to for me to
understand okay wedding for example
because you uh you can marri you got to
get married to a jorgan I I went to
Germany to a wedding so I was right
right and then and then I I tend to to
uh to use um to use the uh this vocab we
cannot see this anymore May okay no I I
just I oh okay you stopped
okay I I will use the this vocab in my
next conversation with with the Tutors
or with my exchange uh uh partner
language exchange partner so I have the
vocab in one uh in one place and I can
access it anywhere okay so you it's an
it's an excellent idea I'm going to show
my own screen and now let's see if this
works again guys this is the first time
it's a first uh let's see now what I'm
going to do is I'm G to try to share my
screen it shouldn't be that complicated
but no that's not slides but but it
looks more difficult than okay so let me
see if I can share and if you can see uh
I think I can share just one at a time I
think you should be able to see it yep
it's working can you guys see it I still
cannot see it on my iPad but I guess
that um it should work so basically this
is my space for learning Turkish I have
something similar for Serbian uh for
Hungarian and for Greek and these are
the languages that I'm learning
basically languages that I call system
one so I'm learning them every single
day so I have the title I have a nice
flag for me visuals are important you
have a description of what this is all
about then here I have a link to the you
cannot see it right now be I'm G to
share this in a second because I cannot
share more than one screen at a time
here is my three Monon challenge we have
it at school so I participate together
with the students because they think
that setting the the example is the most
important thing when it comes to okay
you have to preach uh you know you have
to walk the talk so to speak so hey guys
just do the three month challenge but in
doing it with them it's amazing what it
does to you just like every day sit down
even if I'm tired right so I have this
for Turkish and I have it for Serbian as
well I haven't done Serbian by the way
I'm super tired but I'm going to do it
Tom I'm G to do it right after this
because otherwise my students are going
to throw tomatoes at me and it's the end
of it so here is just like I write d e
stands for exercise these are the
various activities and then I have every
day I do something right I write what I
do my session uh you know for example
here you have second of January session
two unit two talking about aimal here
plus unit one so I do the new um the new
unit and then I go back to the previous
one doing different things to different
uh units and then I go and I have this
basically every I do with this every day
the amazing thing about this is that
every day you open it you have your own
space and then you patch yourself on the
back and say wow I'm doing so much right
so sometimes I I write some notes here
I'm experimenting with Chad GPT I'm
building an entire Chad GPT manual and
it's working wonders like with with
Turkish and um also with my colleague
we're doing it with Greek and guys
you're going to love this so it's
completely changing also it's not
changing completely the way I learn
languages but it's adding something to
it so here you got an idea I don't know
if you guys you can write on the chat
you use some sort of place either
digital or uh on paper where you write
everything you do but I find this uh you
know a little bit OCD as they say a
little bit obsessive but um
you know I think uh I think that it
works for me that's the most important
thing now I stopped sharing my screen uh
specifically I want to share something
else I don't know if people can see
it um you should be able to see that I'm
not sure can you guys see that yep so
basically this is the space of the
channel challenge so some people so
every day you have to fill in you know
days where you uh where you you do a
unit the challenges just put 30 minutes
so some people have not started that
I've put all the people who wanted to
participate but then some people are
participating some others are not
participating but those who are
participating they try to stick to
learning 30 minutes a day doesn't matter
what you do and some people do it some
people don't it's not easy you know but
it's really rewarding at the end you
finish after three months and then you
get a nice reward that is you know
prizes and surprises as they say Okay so
let's go back we have more or less uh
around 20 minutes I'm
flabbergasted at but the craziness the
amount the amount of information that
you write down this is H wow yeah just
I'm a little bit OCD isn't it isn't it
uh interesting to see how how different
we can be like I have
these pieces I have I have them too
actually balam breath our beloved friend
Alex says do you guys ever feel remorse
from how many trees you've killed he
doesn't no no no you know used paper B
breath versus AKA Alex even I don't know
if you guys know but even sending a
simple email is like cutting it well not
exactly cutting an entire tree but it it
it produces carbon dioxide unfortunately
so remember that when you send 3,000
emails you're like just using carbon
dioxide yeah um
so uh we talked about how to start
learning a language we talked about
vocabulary we talked a little bit about
grammar let's talk a little bit about
that if we have time we're going to talk
about we've shown you tur Turkish and
Georgian and how we organize stuff let's
talk a little bit about grammar if we
have some time we're talking about
pronunciation if we don't that's the
topic maybe for another video again guys
at the end I will show you uh well I
will show you I will send you a poll not
today uh but in the in the coming days
on YouTube and you can tell us what
topics we interested in if you like this
show and everything in between now for
an ad again uh guys um I have written
another ebook so I have an ebook that
we're going to put on Amazon paperback
if you guys are interested we're going
to talk about that in the coming days
and weeks but this one ebook is how is
basically about the mistakes that people
commonly make when it comes to learning
a foreign language and you can find tips
for beginners intermediate Learners and
even Advanced Learners and you have the
ebook you have the OT version the pdf
version and on top of that you have the
uh audiobook with my soothing voice
hopefully soothing voice reading the
book just in case you're not interested
in reading and you just want to listen
now let's go back to what we were saying
before let's talk a little bit more
about your favorite topic which is
grammar how do you tackle the grammar of
a close language or a very distant
language let's talk about that let's
break it down first and then if you guys
have any other questions about grammar
specifically please drop them in the
chat so I believe wait a minute I
believe that uh verbs are extremely
important so it is my priority to uh to
get to get used to get familiar with
with uh how verbs work so that I'm able
to express most of my
ideas uh but generally speaking in in as
as far as grammar is concerned I like to
play the the substitution game I call it
that way uh where I have a a set of um
sample sentences very very simple uh and
I try to replace the
elements and to adapt the grammar
accordingly for example if I say if if
my sample sentence is uh I play tennis
every week or once a
week uh and then I want to change
something uh it's my brother so I I I'll
have to say my brother plays
tennis uh and then the rest stays the
same but then I can change it the time
and I can change it to the past and then
I have to say my brother played
yesterday tennis yesterday and so on so
this is just a a very simple example of
how I force myself to adapt the grammar
uh on the go you know so I have the
simple sentence I won't I maybe I'm not
repeating the same thing over and over
again when I already no that sentence
but what I try to force myself to do is
to adapt the grammar very very quickly
as soon as I think a different thing
something that happened yesterday
something that will happen in the future
I have to use the
future that's that's an example of how I
um
Auto um what's the word drill I I I make
myself go through the
drills but in general I love grammar so
I I could I could even uh read a grammar
book like from start to
finish knowing that I'm not going to
learn everything though so it's if if I
if I say this it's not to learn it's to
discover to to discover I like that it's
not to learn but to discover okay
fantastic I'm just going to share my
screen just for a second and
um stepan loves the replacement exercise
or the you know the this there's
different ways of calling that I'm just
going to show you very very quickly
something that I find interesting and
it's in the courses that we teach at the
school these are especially the one that
is coming out about speaking I don't
know if you guys can see it but
basically let's say that I'm learning
Turkish well that's let not suppose I'm
learning Turkish I am learning Turkish
so let's say I've been learning Turkish
for 30 days and I want and this is
actually what I did today I found I
stumbled upon the word I think right and
I wanted to understand how to say I
think now a newbie like someone who's
not doesn't know much about language
learning he would go like this translate
translate the word think in Turkish
right you're not giving it a lot of
context right the word think translates
d d Mech he's just giving you the
infinitive but this is what I'm going to
tell him like I'm going to tell him uh
give me um a quick explanation about the
use of the word of the word think in
Turkish and create and well translate
the following this takes a second
following
sentences from English into Turkish and
put them into a bilingual Table Right
For example so I start with I think okay
I think that or better I
thinking I am thinking about you
I'm I think that in stul is a beautiful
be beautiful city I am thinking of going
to inst stul right explain the grammar
Behind these sentences let's see what
happens right I'm doing this first
exercise just just here this is the base
form of the verb meaning to think so it
gives you the infinitive right so then
it's then it goes like do
look look at the table that it's
building so it's giving me the grammar
explanations it's giving me the the the
you know the table and on top of that
it's explaining the stuff so I think
it's because it's the present right the
present continuous is I'm thinking or I
think it's the same I think I'm thinking
but then you have sh so I'm thinking
about you literally this means about you
I'm thinking because the syntax is the
opposite but then here's but then you
have
[Music]
so I'm thinking that this is at the end
and then you have the entire structure
and then you have
in this is interesting in to in stul gme
means to go but gme is the accusative so
it's like to in stul going the fact I am
thinking right now and it explains this
right so for for
example this translates to I'm thinking
about you here the object is added to
specify what is being thought what what
do I want to say here it's that the
amazing thing about this is that you can
discover grammar in by expanding uh you
you start with another example you can
see what I'm writing right I talk I talk
to you I am talking I want to talk I
want just just a for the verb to talk
right I must talk I think that Chad GPD
even remembers that I want them to
translate so I'm not even giving him the
pro The Prompt I think he's going to
translate by you see so I talk
K so it's the same K to you K I want to
talk K is oh K that's the infinitive
infinitive I want so talk I want I must
talk
K oh okay this is very different so this
gives you a just a sample Le of how I
you can use chat GPT to learn the
grammar of a language just by expanding
like you have you want to understand how
how a word fits how words combine this
is the this is this is a sound of
grammar baby maybe it's not the sound
it's more like the look grammar but is
the is just the expansion it's called
expansion exercises is one of the things
we're going we're going to talk about in
the in the courses coming out in the I
think it's two months it's about
speaking at a l level so it's level one
we call it level one then you got level
two Luka I can tell you I'm so excited
this is the first language that I'm
going to uh to be able to learn with the
help of inter um artificial intelligence
so it's it's going to be very very
exciting to to build it into my way of
learning grammar I can tell you this
every time I sit down in the morning I'm
super excited because I use Asimo I like
it but then with chat GPT I'm building
an entire Asimo for myself
yeah completely personal you can make
your own uh resource I'm creating my own
personalized resource talking about the
stuff I want to talk about this amazing
you're going to see it soon at the
Academy just sign up the newsletter and
uh in the next course it's coming out in
two two in two months I think we're
preparing that you're gonna love this I
I promise that anyway
so uh do you use chat gbt to speak to it
as well clao uh not yet uh I use
chbd exclusively now to understand
grammar when when I have you know when I
have some some doubts but I'm using it
in other ways as well so it's not just
expansion it's a replacement exercises I
use pieces of paper to arrange different
pieces to form sentences I'm having an
amazing time use tables on Chad GPT I
still not revealing what I'm doing but I
can tell you that it's just I'm having
the time of my life this sounds
exaggerated but it's exactly it another
question that I wanted to address here
is in Russian so I'm gonna translate for
you like what is
that so basically basically this means
in the Russian language literally it's
important to learn grammar yes it's
true or it's just or you just have to
remember
um
uh it just like what do you call what do
you call sentences yeah like for example
fixed Expressions that's exact right so
you think it's would you just learn
fixed expressions and
just you're asking me
about I I you're right you're right I
know I have a a comprehensible thing
again a comprehensive approach towards
learning grammar is learning how words
combine together so again if you want to
learn Russi and you can
say I want to learn but then you have or
you can you can start by by by by
telling chpt I'm I'm talking from the
perspective of an English speaker for
example oh I I want to go for I want to
go as a very ambiguous uh I want to go
with a friend well is that a girl is
that a boy you want to go just once you
want to go by car by bus and Russian has
this right for
example for example um there's so many
uh they're called move verbs of movement
and this is in Slavic languages it's
it's it's kind of complicated so you
learn by giving instructions by Trying
by context by learning through massive
exposure but also experimenting with
chat GPT and you know it's you have to
learn the grammar holistically and
globally and and please understand that
you do not have to love grammar to learn
it and to use it
grammar should be should be learned and
used like what how how is this how how
does the saying go uh as much as
necessary but as little as possible
that's I love it love it I leave you
with that I I I love it so Luigi says
thank you very much for showing that
with chat GPT Luca I never thought about
it Luigi I have so many different
instructions different amazing things
you can do I I just can't show like I
can't wait to show you what's in store
for you guys especially sky the limit
the sky it's really the sky the limit
this this is just one very short example
of what can be done especially the
amazing thing is that I started using
this from the get-go I'm never a
proponent of starting to speak from the
get-go but you can start experimenting
and you you know using the language or
trying to create something output is not
necessarily speaking output can also be
forming sentences like repeating uh you
know fixed structures like walking down
the aisle and and and do this sort of
stuff so um you can do anything you want
if you learn how to use the amazing
tools that we have nowadays now we still
have five minutes we'll stretch you to
10 because at 85 I think your family is
waiting they're they're waiting
somewhere and so I understand you're a
family man um you're a married man in a
family man
so um we have talked about let me see
here we have how to start we talked
about mindset we talked about vocabulary
we talked about grammar how to use a
little bit chat GPT chat GPT can be used
also for vocabulary apart from grammar
amazing ways in which you can do that
again guys you're interested in this we
can do another live or I can do a demo
uh you have to come to the school though
because we have also Zoom meetings we
have lives there and we also got to do
some stuff uh obviously here on the
internet if you're interested yes it's
called cloudia clao asks has it ever
happened that chat GPT makes mistakes
it's called hallucination that's a
technical term when when the when the AI
hallucinates makes mistakes because it's
still made by men and men make mistakes
let's talk last but not least a little
bit about pronunciation now I thought I
thought we were uh we we totally wanted
to talk about self-organization right
isn't it oh yes okay no maybe that's
even more
important I think that's even more
important that pronunciation is
important and and and I can tell you
Stephan's got amazing pronunciation
across all these languages but I think
that self organization is really
important I want to make this premise
because there's not a lot of time left
I'm reading a great book I don't know if
you ever heard of fluent for free by
span Maria span so I'm just gonna write
it here because it's a great book Maria
span I met her last year uh fluent for
free which is and I'm gonna talk about
it on YouTube by the way I'm going to
make a video about this book and she
talks about in the in the in the premise
at the at the beginning of the book she
says that one of was struck struck aord
with me and it's absolutely true is that
we tend to think that the same me why
does the same method let's say you look
you watch a video by LCA larel you watch
a video by Stefano you watch a video by
poly X and you try their method and it
doesn't work with you works with them
doesn't work with you course because
everybody is different and maybe you
don't like the the system but there's
another important thing to talk about
it's your soft skills there's a lot of
skill when when you when you consider a
skilled polyot it's not just the skill
set it's not just their capacity to
learn vocabulary words grammar Etc it's
also their capacity their mindset and
their capacity to self-organize organize
their time organize their energy and a
lot of other soft skills that come with
successful learning so let's talk about
that how do you organize your time this
is really important a lot of people say
how the hell can I learn a language if
I'm always like you know I have to learn
I have to go to university someone asked
this question before I am doing engineer
like like as I did
uh got you got a family got children
running around running around and all
sorts of problems how do you cope with
that how do you organize your time what
are the the tips that you can share you
have five minutes the tips you can share
when it comes to organizing your time in
order to learn a language on a regular
basis all right so uh first of all I'll
start by telling you that I used to
[Laughter]
suck like okay that okay said it what
but it's like I used to s
I used to be really really bad
organizing myself but starting from like
January this year
uh at the same time as I was starting
the new language Turkish uh I have found
the key to learning every day a little
bit a little bit so creating your own
routine is so powerful uh like I I've
made a packed with myself and uh I've
decided okay every single morning after
breakfast and the kids go to school Etc
at 8 o'clock I'll be down in my office
like where I am right
now doing
language that's it language uh so three
times a a week I do Turkish twice a week
I do Georgian that's five days a week
that's enough like for for 30 minutes
nothing impossible nothing in
enormous I'm just I've just decided that
I'll start working at 8:30 okay I'm an
independent I work as an independent so
uh I can organize my work time that's uh
that's great obviously not everybody can
do that uh but there are other uh time
slots that you can uh you can decide
you're going to learn a language in and
and this this this has
such it has had such an impact on on my
life in general I'm much more satisfied
at at the end of the morning like come
12:00 I'm so so much more satisfied
about myself because I've done what I
really want to do what I really like to
do that's learning languages I also do
some uh working out also uh like around
8:30 until 9 maybe uh and I didn't know
that having it such a routine could be
this effective and have such a positive
impact on my general being not only
on you know how much uh how much I learn
languages of course it's going to have a
great impact on my Turkish because if I
don't
learn I I won't be speaking Turkish
anytime soon but on my well-being in
general and and personal satisfaction in
general that that has like changed
everything starting from this year and I
I hope I can keep this uh this pace but
it's looking good it's really looking
like excellent I'm glad on the right
path I'm you're definitely on the right
path so let me just uh share my screen
got to talk about this for a second and
then uh we're going to close closing
words I don't know if you guys can see
this is a little bit of my craziness so
um for me it's really important to if
you don't plan it it's not going to
happen so I have this is an example of
April 2024 still hasn't happened but it
just just showing you the kind of setup
that I have every month then before the
month happens I um make sure that I kind
of tweak things around but the bottom
line is that if you can see I work in
blocks so it's I have my morning routine
and in my morning routine I always write
these things like Journal food like I
talk about food journal Journal of
self-awareness um and I have uh you know
inside I already have everything
prepared so uh for example I know that I
create this anchoring right I finish my
morning routine which is basically you
know journaling uh meditation for 30
minutes everything is included there
then I start my cardio training or
strength training depending on on you
know on the circumstances and then I do
Turkish for an hour then I deep work for
four five hours depending then I have
lunch reading which is really important
for me uh and then I have running
normally go running then I have Greek
Hungarian Serbian there's other things
that are not included here because then
I add them but the bottom line of this
is that basically what I do is that I
structure my day so that I know it's
again it's a little bit I'm a little bit
extreme in this but but it works if you
leave if you think I have time or I
don't have time to learn languages it
ain't going to happen well if you uh for
first you have a schedule and you think
okay this is like this is what's going
to happen uh in the morning so I know
that in the morning I'm fresh I'm got to
do Turkish I'm got to do Turkish for an
hour I have that time slot and there's a
law that is really interesting which
which is called Alzheimer's law not that
Alzheimer about the illness but it's
called it basically states that you fill
in the time that you're given so if you
have an hour you're going to make a
count I have an hour I have 30 minutes
you divide it in blocks and then you
anchor um so there's much more to talk
much more about it that you know that
meets the eye as they say uh but we can
talk about it next uh the next time so
let me wrap wrap it up just just a quick
addition maybe uh it really depends also
on on the phase of your life because
when like 20 years ago when I was a
student or I had more time I only used
my idol time during the day it used to
be much more now I have family two kids
uh three jobs and like if I don't find
the slot that I dedicate to language
learning I know I won't make it so
that's why I I decided to to try this
new routine and it's working but it
probably wouldn't have worked 10 even 10
years ago you know uh so it's important
to to understand how the the phase of
your life is also going to to play to
play a big role I think yes absolutely
there's so many factors you have to
factor in your life the phase of your
life the level of your language so again
I've just shown you just giving you a
sample and example of how I structure my
day but then it really depends on the
month it depends on the year it depends
on the languages there you could see
that I'm learning four languages at the
same time Turkish is the newborn so you
know you needs more attention in the
morning when I'm fresh and then you have
the three other languages I squeeze in
during the day while I go running for
example taking a shower and they have
airpods Etc anyway so let's wrap it up
washing up washing the washing up is the
washing up is is spectacular there's so
many errands that we run every day and
this so-call that time where we can just
listen listen is easy and you can listen
if especially when when you're not a
beginner anymore you can listen uh to
podcasts but even if you're a beginner
you can always listen to stuff youve
already
you know read and listen to at the same
time so you can always review stuff you
can always use listening while running
errands to actually um spend time with
the language and review stuff okay let
me wrap it up once again thank you very
much for watching everybody this has
been amazing it I didn't have I had no
doubt that it would be just as great as
it came out to be um I hope you liked it
we tried it again we trying streamyard
because um I think that answering the
Q&A is fine but I think that Al showing
more stuff what we do for example I give
you a quick demonstration of chat GPT of
how I use chat GPT for uh for you know
discovering grammar not learning but
discovering um Stefano showed you showed
us a beautiful georan and how he
organizes vocabulary so he always has it
with him on the phone uh and uh we we
showed you a few other uh few other
things yes fluent for free looks like a
paid ebook OG says it's yes uh you have
you have to buy the book you know just I
I think there's I think there's a value
I think it's actually how it works I
think you can find it on the internet if
you want but I would highly recommend to
spend money on it because this person
Maria has done an amazing job has put a
lot of time to make you learn a language
for free you know so I think it's worth
the investment spending some 10 EUR or
20 Euro uh and she's not paying me any
by the way I'm just I just I'm just
recommending good books and this is what
I'm going to start talking about you
know in the live shows but so um I think
in in our next YouTube videos um show my
books and show why I like these books um
anyway Stefano again I'm gonna just
write here the last
ad of the day we have Ling I don't know
why you can't write on the chat it's
kind of strange linga let me write it
here so um thank you I wrote
lingua because I wrote
l
l yeah oh my God okay uh all right so
here is Ling not l so there you have it
and I will show it here it's just right
Ling with person you will find it and
last but not least again guys if you
want you can take a look uh just going
to share my screen one last time because
I can I like sharing my screen just like
why you're sharing your screen so much
because I can so um here is uh you can
see my website and you can sign up to
get this freebook it's about avoid these
critical mistakes it's an 80 page eBook
PDF EOB so you can put on your Kindle if
you want or you can even listen to it so
all you need to do is send me the free
ebook and it will ask you are you a
beginner are you an intermediate are you
an advanced because depending on the
level you have then we will give you
different tips and um I think that is it
um James says he's absolutely right
that's Parkinson law I confuse it with
Alzheimer we were getting close it's the
same realm unfortunately but it's
Parkinson's law and not Alzheimer's law
I'm sorry about that and and James is
absolutely correct but the the law is
always you know it stays the same it's
just you know you fill in the time that
you're giving like you give yourself a
task you have an hour to complete the
task you have to complete the task by
that hour you work better than if you
have eight hours that's how the entire
working system uh is is based upon well
we have eight hours how many people
actually work for eight hours it's much
better to have four hours because those
four hours you can compress that amount
of of of of work and then you have free
time later which is just what scandin
some Scandinavian Scandinavian countries
the kind of system that some
Scandinavian countries are
adopting so let me wrap it up um thank
you very much for everything guys for
the am amazing questions we're trying
different things again if you like this
please let me
know how do you say uh gracias in in in
Finnish Koso Koso I don't know I know
Kos I like say
Kos um and uh I think on YouTube we can
run a poll asking specific questions so
we're gonna ask you guys questions did
you like this let us know in the
comments now uh take two minutes to if
you have the time did you like this uh
this show why did you like it uh did you
find it interesting that we talked about
this is there any topic that you would
like us to discuss so me and Stefan in
particular remember Stephano Stefan how
many languag you speak and Which
languages you speak we didn't talk about
that oh we didn't yeah so uh Italian is
my native language uh I can speak uh so
English German Portuguese Finnish French
Romanian to a high level and then I'm
intermediate in
Spanish Japanese and Icelandic and the
beginner in Georgian Mandarin Chinese
and Turkish of course and Turkish of
course okay so um again guys I hope you
liked it again we're gonna send you a
poll um thank you very much guys Luigi
says I loved it and I do follow also
your channels keep calling me old
mockers thanks thank you get through
says I liked it it was
great
says says
um we one more thing that I wanted to
say uh Stephan and I will probably do
some more stuff even more in-depth
within the academy so in the future in
the coming future so if you're
interested in uh Tanya I know Tanya uh
from Moscow hi Tanya
PR is the guy from the 10 the Clos
Master challenge the guy's been
obsessing about the the challenge thank
you for reminding us about the channel
we're going to do that uh expect some
other videos from us because we're going
to make some more videos for you not
live but if you want we also do live but
expect some funny videos from us
entertaining hope uh and branka branca
is another friend of mine uh she helped
me learn Serbian and she says um you
know OD means you're you guys are great
OD means and perfect
actuallya meanso means thank you very
much and uh I think this is really it
now I have to figure out how to end this
stream
right we may stay on
forever whole night the whole night you
I was I was even thinking about you know
we could do a live of learning with us
it's like a live
show mind it would be fun where you see
what I do live when I I learn Turkish so
uh again we have a lot of
ideas and
uh and uh now we're gonna figure out how
to end the live streaming it's on you
it's on you I can't do yes yes and um
and um and that's it uh again expect a
poll from us we're gonna ask a few
questions and again thank you everyone
thank you so much it was fun have a
fantastic weekend chow chow guys
guys